(pop music)
- [Chance] How many people
have the opportunity
to be a world champion at anything?
We have the opportunity to do something
that no one else does.
This isn't played anywhere
else in the world.
So yeah, like, it's serious.
Like, we want to win.
(pop music)
- We're here to watch Unicycle Football.
It's football on unicycles.
(rock music)
- We stick to NFL rules
as closely as possible.
Except are a few exceptions
because we're riding a unicycle.
- We play five on five,
two receivers, a blocker,
a center, and a quarterback.
Everything has to be done on a wheel.
The second your foot touches the ground,
you're done.
- Each team plays 14 games,
there's 56 regular season games total.
Then wild card playoffs, then playoffs,
and then the Stupor Bowl.
- Every Sunday,
some people have been doing
this for 10 years now.
My team the Blackouts, we're undefeated,
and we're going to be
playing the reigning champs,
the Herons.
- Bulldoze them over.
Bulldoze them.
- [Charlie] This game is very important
because we want to maintain
our undefeated status leading
up to the Stupor Bowl.
- [Dane] They're
definitely gunning for us.
They're practicing just for us.
(pop music)
- [Charlie] I think that a lot of times
people come to this game.
What shocks them is the level of play.
We're crashing at 15 miles an hour.
It's not a joke.
Some people get seriously injured.
- [Dane] Most people learn to
ride unicycle because they came
and witnessed this event.
And like I've got to do this.
- Once you catch that first ball,
once you get that first rush,
once you hear the crowd
scream your name once,
it's a feeling you
can't get anywhere else.
- It's almost like a
religion, church to us here.
- There's passion, you know, it's a show,
it's a spectacle.
It's also a sport.
I've cherished every minute of it.
You can't replace it,
with anything,
there's nothing else like it,
at all.
(pop music)